what would the Earth be like
first let's talk about where your
country would be located North America
would be right here Europe would be a
lot closer just to the east
Asia would be up north by Russia and
Antarctica would remain down south
India and Australia would be further
south connected to Antarctica
these countries that used to have hot
climates would now be cold covered with
snow and ice
and those wouldn't be the only
environmental changes regions in the
middle of Pangea would have Lush
rainforests along their borders
and as you travel further Inland it
would become a desert
this would be due to pangea's land mass
being so large
rain which comes from the ocean wouldn't
be able to travel far enough inland
leaving parts of Pangea practically
uninhabitable by humans and other
species